that is crazy obviously you're a very
smart you're you know I think um we're
gonna get to like just your accolades
it's just not only just the artist but
you're you're you know I think you're
one of the when we talk about CEOs eyes
for talent you're one of them ones um
how would you say since 2008 what have
been the biggest things about the music
industry that has I know obviously Tick
Tock streaming all that but just in
terms of like you know from when you
first got into the game to now is there
anything that you dislike about the
current uh for like like music forecast
um anything that I dislike about the
music forecast honestly the only thing
that I can probably say that uh would
put a negative stamp on is the
originality yeah I just think there's
not enough Variety in hip-hop like
everything sound the same this is true
that's the only thing that I dislike
about it but I love the hustle
um I love the opportunity that that the
hip top is bringing to everybody else I
love the um
you know it's it's literally taking well
should take [ __ ] out the hood but
it's it's creating opportunities that we
didn't have before for sure because
before it was either it was either it
was either music or basketball right
right okay now basketball's still
regulated so you can't just jump into
that yeah you got to be like you're
right an alien level athlete
whereas music anybody can do it it don't
even matter like you can just any
anybody can just go in the room now and
just get on you know GarageBand and make
a record and go to straight to
SoundCloud and go straight up to
SoundCloud because when you got signed
did you get signed off of a demo tape
which was kind of like back in the day I
got I got actually signed out of
creating demos wow which is interesting
because I started off as a producer
songwriter first and I would write songs
for other artists right so at one point
you know they heard my record it was
like man it's a dope record I would love
him to write for all right for our
artist but who's the guy singing on the
songs right who's that you know what I
mean and that's how I got pretty much
discovered